hello everyone thank you for joining me
in this course
i'm really excited to share with you
about twitter for business and how you
can
celebrate your business growth through
twitter ads my name is edward suber and
i'm the marketing lead for the small
businesses in twitter asia pacific
my job is to have small to medium-sized
businesses uncover their true potential
on twitter
and how they can meet their business
goals through twitter ads
i ran a couple of businesses previously
so i can definitely relate to you guys
about what you guys do
how important i always to you guys and
what are the marketing metrics you guys
truly care about
so be rest assured that i'll make sure
you get spine values in all my
presentations
if you have any questions comments along
the way feel free to tweet to me at
sbr my handle is just right there in
this course you'll learn in detail
about what benefits for businesses to
get on twitter
how to target the right audience through
our robust targeting signals
and what are the three steps to success
on twitter ads finally we'll wrap up
with
a number of case studies and best
practices
your success metrics by the end this
course is to
one understand the value of twitter for
your business
and two how to set a successful campaign
on twitter ads if you made these two
goals by the end of this course that
means i've done a great job in
presenting and you've done an excellent
job
in applying your new knowledge alright
what do you see
if we kickstart the fun now